The joe rogan experience.
I think,
um,
William James was one of the,
one of the guys who really did a good job of that saying basically,
you know,
if I may be right about this way of thinking,
but even if I'm not thinking this way allows me to lead a better life.
And I think he was talking about free will and he was basically saying,
look,
I don't know if we have freewill or I don't know if everything we do is based on
a causal chain of events that we really can't control.
But thinking about free will in a way that it does exist allows me to live a
better life.
And so guess what,
I am a proponent of freewill because that allows me to live a better life that
way.
Cause I feel like I have more flexibility,
more choice.
I'm a happier person.
And I think sometimes people forget some of that too.
You know?
I mean there's something to be said for thinking about things.
Even if you don't know,
you know,
think about things in a,
in a way that's going to allow you to lead the best life.
And you know,
way better than if you don't know any ways you think about something in a way
that fucking sucks.
Like,
Oh,
I'm going to go to hell for sure.
Well,
if you're wrong in that you've lived a life being afraid and being worried about
shit,
man,
you were wrong.
Might as well think in a positive way.
And it's still,
you still may turn out to be wrong,
but hey,
along the way you lived in a better way.
Yeah.
Sounds like someone is starting a cult.
That's what I just heard.
I heard it.
Yeah.
No,
no doubt man.
I mean there's a,
I think it's couldn't,
it might not be either or as well.
It might be another one of those situations.
Yeah.
You know,
it,
uh,
there's this,
I think there's a lot of things going on.
There's a lot of things going on in this life and um,
I think we should acknowledge all of them.
You know,
we should acknowledge the most importantly,
the mystery of it all.
That's one of the big things that drives me crazy about someone when they say,
you know that this is this and that is that in the,
you know,
the way you should live is this,
and the way the government should do is that,
and the way we're going to solve this is by that.
Like maybe not,
maybe not like are you,
are you really so sure that you're paying attention to what the fuck is going
on?
We're flying through space like we're on a spaceship.
Spaceship was a hundred feet wide.
You'd be freaking the fuck out right now.
The only reason why you're not freaking out,
it's because it's like thousands of miles wide,
but it's still a space ship.
You're on this spinning fucking thing.
And at nighttime you could see the space you're flying through and you spinning
a thousand miles an hour in a circle and your hose floating around this giant
nuclear explosion.
And that's around other bigger rocks that are flying behind you and gas giants.
And then other galaxies and other universe has an on and on and on and you just
hurdling through it while you're worried about what's on TV and why the walking
dead is so many commercials and why gas is $4.
And if you imagine,
if this was,
let's say,
put yourself in a position where this really was a dream and you had a lucid
dream where you're aware,
is that what you would want to do with your dream?
If you're going to sleep at night and you were saying you would worry about all
of these inane things,
never actually be in the present,
never taken adventure,
never go on a risk,
never love because you could get hurt.
Now if you,
if this,
if you really did treat this like a dream,
you would do as much cool shit as possible.
You know,
put his,
put as many good things into that dream as he possibly could and not not be so
fucking stressed out about all this nonsense.
You know,
and,
and I think we've been talking a lot,
it's kinda been the theme of this podcast,
but if you actually did,
if this was a lucid dream,
you know you would live it in a different way.
You would live it to have some fun and enjoy it.
Like what can I fly cause all my lucid dreams I want to fly or breathe
underwater.
Breathing underwater is cool too.
That's a good one.
Yeah,
it would be very strange if one day it was,
it was proven that we are really living in some sort of self created reality.
It would be like a really traumatizing for a lot of people that have fucked it
up.
We'd be like,
this is what I made.
But it's like remember when you were in school and like there was a project and
you had to use your hand and make a Turkey and you put your hand down.
He drew around and then you know,
everybody's got their own little Turkey painted it and then the teacher would
put them up with new and I'll look at them.
Some people's,
Turkey's looked like dog shit.
I looked,
I didn't know what the fuck a Turkey looked like.
They didn't even know how to draw around their hand.
Like everything was a disaster and other people that beautiful darkies well your
life is a work of art.
Your life is like a hand Turkey that you make in grade school.
It's,
you could do whatever you want with that thing.
You can make it super dope.
You know you can,
you can make it so it looks really cool if you put the effort and time into it,
if you really focus on it or you could just half ass that mother fucker and
trial bunch of squiggly things don't look anything like fingers.
Some eyeballs are floating above his stupid fake Turkey head and everybody's
like,
what the fuck's wrong with Bob?
He's like on test takers got cancer.
I think one of the,
one of the coolest pieces that I've seen,
and I have to go to the bathroom,
so I don't know if you want to play,
but it's a Alan,
it's called Alan Watts.
Inception,
is the name of the video on Google,
and he talks about,
it's a great video.
Okay.